last night we poured ourselves a couple
of uh you know a couple of glasses of
Tara mana we had a nice little toast of
gratitude and then we started practicing
making babies again you're welcome
according to Dwayne Johnson self
quarantine has turned into baby-making
season show - why the comedy rocker the
actor joked about how self-isolation has
been affecting his marriage with wife
Lauren hash Ian after being axed by a
fan I have found that the that the
quarantine has had a very positive
effect on my relationship in my marriage
Dewayne also revealed that while
everything is good now the couple got
off to a rocky start I gotta be honest
with you you know when we when this
thing first started the first two weeks
of quarantine for me I was really wobbly
at times and I was trying to get my foot
together and trying to understand it
because I was just also thinking trying
to think ten steps ahead what does the
future look like what is the new normal
gonna look like when I go back work
school my household what you know so
there's a lot of there's a lot of but
that we're all thinking about husbands
wives you name it we're all thinking
about this so it's a lot of pressure the
dad of three we went on to share his
take on how having empathy for your
partner during Bea's uncertain times can
make a world of difference we also
really make sure that we still try to
stay aware as a husband and wife and
this goes for a husband and wife
boyfriend girlfriend best friends
whoever you're locked down with we try
to understand that you know this is
still an Incred you know things are
quiet and the pace has really slowed
down for all of us around the world it's
still an incredible amount of pressure
because we just don't know and it's the
fear of the unknown
and how that can
the relationship how can that can impact
mental wellness so we try to go easy on
each other we try to make things light
not to judgey Dwayne and Lauren got
secretly married after 12 years together
in August of 2019 the couple shares two
girls Jasmine who is four into year-old
tiana mama Lauren is doing great baby T
is getting big baby jazzy is loving her
little sister just yeah everything is
great
the Jumanji next level star is also a
father to eighteen-year-old Simone from
his first marriage before Dewayne ended
his Q&A video he had one more message
for fans and I hope this helps you guys
around the world it's not easy that it
is not easy
you're locked down and you know you're
with your party partner your loved one
husband wife boyfriend girlfriend and I
get it's not easy but but we're gonna go
through we're gonna get through this on
the other side and hopefully my marriage
and your marriage and all your
relationships are going to be better on
the other side of this thing all right
most importantly stay healthy and stay
safe
[Music]